Paul Johnson director of The Institute
for fiscal studies joins me now good to
see you Paul so the UK on course then to
borrow 30 billion pounds less than
forecast that we've talked a little bit
about it but just explain in a bit more
detail why
well the first thing that say it's less
than forecast last November but still
tens of billions of pounds more than
forecast last March we're still in a
much worse position than we were a year
ago it's just that things look a little
bit better than they did in November why
is that well that's partly as you say
because Energy prices have come down and
therefore the energy support package is
less expensive it's also as it happens
because we seem to be getting more tax
revenue in than was expected that might
be because the economy is doing a bit
better than expected it might be because
the kind of what limited growth we are
getting is a bit more tax Rich than we
expected before so the numbers look a
bit better this year than we thought
just a couple of months ago very
important to be clear still really quite
bad and much worse than a year ago
what's really going to matter to the
chancellor is what things look like two
three four years down the road and for
that we're going to have to wait for
what the officer budget responsibility
tells him about their view of the
economy okay now you might you might
have already answered a little bit of my
next question then be because many
people will say well look we've heard
tonight on the news that more strikes
are happening across the public sector
why can't public sector workers get the
pay Rises they want if there is more
money sloshing around
well of course that is a choice for the
government and the government can choose
to give public sector workers more and
given what's happened to their pay over
the last not just the last year but the
last 12 years there's clearly a case for
that public sector pay nurses and
teachers and Saudis 10 15 below where it
was in 2010 and that's not been the case
across most of the private sector so
there's clearly a case for doing
something there not least because we
need to recruit and retain those
teachers nurses and so on but it's quite
expensive I mean to match well what the
private sector got this year we're
looking at you know several billion
maybe nine billion pounds they're
spending another several billion in the
next financial year now that's quite
expensive and that costs money into the
long term the government's going to be
worried about that does it have an
impact on borrowing in the long run they
might decide that they can borrow some
more they might decide actually that
they need to put taxes up a little
little bit to pay for that they might
decide to cut other aspects of spending
on their mind side that they will impose
those big pay cuts on the public sector
worker so as ever there is a choice here
it's not right to say things can't be
afforded it's a question of the choices
the government makes about what it
spends money on and just clear something
else up for me when the government says
uh pay Rises across the public sector
would increase inflation is that right
in your view
I don't think that's a significant worry
so we've already got a world in which
what's happening in the public sector is
well behind the private sector so if you
increase wages in the public sector
that's not going to drive up wage
demands in the private sector I don't
think that's a worry the other Warrior
government might have is if they're
putting more money into the economy by
putting up wages whilst borrowing more
that might be a problem well in the
short run given that it looks like we'll
be borrowing Less in the next year or so
that shouldn't be too much of a worrying
in the long run of course a we hope
inflation will come down and be
um there are also choices about taking
more money out in terms of taxing I
think the issue is much more one about
the public finances than it is about an
impact of increasing wages
um the impact that might have on
inflation okay very interesting um
obviously energy is a big source of
concern for people at the moment and and
we've touched on this already but labor
is suggesting extending the energy
support that's available for households
I mean is that feasible for the
government given the The Current
financial situation what are your
thoughts on that
well at the moment of course
um bills are the average bill is held at
this amount which equates to 2 500
pounds a year uh the government's saying
that will go up to three thousand pounds
a year in in April that doesn't mean
everyone's built through up three
thousand pounds for the cap will be
increased now what we now know or expect
will happen to Energy prices is that
from the summer they will come down
anyway to something around that two and
a half thousand pounds Mark so the
consequence of that is that keeping the
cap at two and a half thousand pounds
it's really only likely to bite
um in the next quarter of this year so
April May uh June and it'll be not
terribly expensive in the order of two
billion pounds now that's a one-off uh
cost uh that's something the government
could easily afford within its um within
the money that it's that it's got it
doesn't make a huge amount of difference
of course because this is uh people's
bills fall in the spring but it will
help some some households if that's what
the government decides to do it's
certainly affordable it's one of the
things I'm sure they're considering